jetzt kommt sozusagen die Diskussion
also wir haben gerade festgestellt
glaube ich hat jetzt irgendwie jeder
verstanden oder ich habe es zumindest
für mich jetzt herausgezogen sie sagen
an die Frage ob der die Klimaveränderung
auf die Menschen gemacht ist oder nicht
die stellt sich für die stellt sich
nicht mehr nicht und die stellt sich für
gibt es Wissenschaftler die das
Unterschreiben
dürfen
ich glaube
das Beste was man hier jetzt sagen kann
wenn es um die Wissenschaft geht und ob
sie wirklich
die ganze Wissenschaft ist oder nicht
ist die Tatsache dass zwei Klimaforscher
von denen einer man dr Vater gewesen ist
2021 den Physik Nobelpreis Klasse Sommer
genau Hamburger ja in Hamburg geboren
und ähm in der Laudatio steht also für
die Erkennung des menschlichen
Einflusses auf das Klima und für die
real falsche Vorhersage der
Klimaentwicklung das haben die eine 90er
1990er Jahren gemacht na das heißt also
schon vor Jahrzehnten haben dann auch
vorher gesagt okay wie würde sich unser
Klima entwickeln ja und deswegen muss
man schon sagen ich meine mehr Atmung
kann man einfach nicht bekommen als in
Physik-Nobelpreis wenn man jetzt
bestreitet dass das Physik
dass das Nobelpreiskomitee irgendwie das
blödmännern besteht oder eine verengte
Sicht auf die Dinge hat dann hat man
sich am Ende von der Wissenschaft
abgekoppelt
er kommt gerade jetzt haben wir schon
wieder eine Veränderung genau und der
Diskussion
so eine Art Diskreditierung derjenigen
betrieben die also dort eine andere
Meinung haben und die gibt's in der Tat
und diesen Weg diesen diesen Konsens in
der Wissenschaft den gibt's ja nicht im
glaube vor anderen auf der Spiegel muss
ja zugeben also diese 97% des Konsens
das allerwissenschaftler den gibt's ja
nicht da muss
haben wir auch schon oft geschrieben
haben wir gelesen dass das nicht so ist
wir haben verschiedenste Ebenen
diesen Konsens gibt es nicht genau wo
wer sind die Leute namhafte
Wissenschaftler auf die sie sich berufen
sie sagten gerade sehr interessant die
haben eine andere Meinung aber das das
kommt durchaus an der einen oder anderen
Stelle hervor es gibt durchaus äh
Menschen Leute die am äh
wissenschaftlichen oder am Bericht des
ipcs mitgearbeitet haben die sich heute
davon abwenden
das spielt keine Rolle Lünen zum
Beispiel
und hat mitgearbeitet am Bericht oder
nehmen sie auch hören wollt hier der
also durchaus dort nach ehemaligen
Hamburg
ich stelle Ihnen eine klare Frage und
sagen welche Wissenschaftler und ich
würde gerne wissen genau
aber sie halten die Antwort ich suche
die raus ich bringe die morgen auf meine
Webseite und dann können wir da gerne
weiter diskutieren
genau sie müssen unterscheiden zwischen
Meinung und Wissenschaft ja
momentan die Leute die sind ja Klima
Forscher und dann gibt's viele Geologen
die also auch durchaus anderen Blick auf
die Zeit haben wir haben schon
festgestellt wir haben Warmzeiten auch
gehabt wir haben eine mittelalterliche
Warmzeit gehabt da konnte man zu Fuß
durch das Bett der Donau gehen weil kein
Wasser mehr da war in England hatten wir
Weinbau das heißt das was wir jetzt
bekommen ist nichts Neues und wir hatten
in der Vergangenheit auch immer eine
blöde mit der Gesellschaft was wir jetzt
erleben
das hat geblüht
Durcheinander
mit einer globalen Erwärmung jetzt zu
tun das war während der
mitteilungsbeschleunigen Moment das war
während der mittelalterlichen Warmzeit
nicht so das war ein regionales Ereignis
das war während der kleinen Eiszeit
natürlich habe die da äh auch nicht so
das heißt also dass er jetzt in den
letzten Jahrzehnten erlebt haben ist
einzigartig und er schreibt auch der
Welt
klimaat es ist einzigartig Moment es ist
auch einzigartig für die letzten 2000
Jahren und das ist einige andere
nicht sagen das sind aber mein Problem
das sind keine wissenschaftlichen Arbeit
auch dass viele sich gar nicht mehr
trauen sich dazu zu äußern kann wir
haben eine völlige forschungsland
überhaupt weg vom Fenster leider nicht
also wenn ich das Fernsehen anmache dann
habe ich immer das Gefühl also morgen
fällt uns der Himmel auf dem Kopf und
es ist ganz schlimm und wir müssen
sofort auf den nächsten Planeten und
leider wird gut ich habe noch einmal
ganz kurz ich versuchen kann und dann
kommen wir gleich zu Frau Mann bitte
nützt nichts für uns alle die ganze Zeit
unterbrechen ich will sie gerne ihre
Argument machen lassen aber versuchen
Sie bitte einfach nur auf die simple
Frage zu antworten
und nicht alarmistisch und ohne
schaumverbot sie sagten gerade viele
Wissenschaftler sehen das anders sie
sind energiepolitischer Sprecher der AFD
richtig beschäftigen sich mit diesem
Thema wir haben Sie eingeladen weil sie
wussten es geht um dieses Thema heute
ich finde es gut dass sie diese
Einladung gefolgt sind und deswegen wenn
sie sich damit beschäftigt haben noch
mal die Frage wer sind die
Wissenschaftler auf die sie sich berufen
wir müssen mal das Gesamtbild betrachten
Herr lands und in diesem Gesamtbild da
gibt es Einzelmeinung da gibt es
durchaus auch viele die dort folgen
unbedingt einsparen wollen aber schon
bei der Menge wie wirkt CO2 da haben wir
keine Antwort also wird zwar immer
gesagt ja CO2 ist ein Treibhausgas das
ist ja richtig und sicherlich wird CO2
auch ein Beitrag dazu leisten dass das
Klima sich verändert aber schon in der
Erklärung wie hoch denn die Wirkung von
CO2 ist da gibt es keine Antwort das
stimmt was eben auch
eine Sache kurz klar stehen keiner
derjenige die hier sitzen niemand
bezweifelt dass wir eine Veränderung des
Klimas haben das tun sie auch nicht sie
ist das sehen Sie auch bei sich im
Brandenburg ist ja die Situation dass
wir halt und so weiter halbes Jahr lang
ordentlich geregnet also das sehe ich
weniger also die letzten Jahre
Brandenburg würde ich sagen wir fragen
den Experten sie haben da ein Thema
sicherlich und das ist eine Kornkammer
nicht nur für uns sondern eigentlich für
einen guten Teil Westeuropas also wir
haben dann Thema sehen uns eigentlich
oder würden Sie sagen es gibt gar keine
Frage ist welches
also aus meiner Sicht ist es kein Thema
unbedingt die Wirtschaft jetzt Platz zu
machen CO2 unbedingt zu vermeiden
sondern die Gesellschaft
gegen diese Klimaveränderung zu machen
okay und noch mal die simple Frage oder
ich kann sie mir eigentlich auch sparen
das heißt welcher Wissenschaftler sagt
ihnen der Wissenschaftler dieser
Klimawandel der gerade stattfinden ist
nicht Menschen gemacht
nehmen wir zum Beispiel den
Physik-Nobelpreisträger anton Zeilinger
er sagt ganz klar der Physik
Nobelpreisen Jahren der beschäftigt sich
beschäftigt sich auch mit diesem Thema
auch vor allen Dingen mit der
Wissenschaftler
funktioniert so dass man ganz klar die
Wissenschaft darf sich nicht hinstellen
und sagen sie kann sicher sagen wie die
Zukunft sein
metalloge ist der Ozeanograph ist der
genau das der hat die Wissenschaft auch
im Blickpunkt und wir reden von
Wissenschaft okay wir könnten
wie hoch ist der Einfluss von CO2 wie
ist das nicht klar das geht auch aus den
Veröffentlichungen nicht hervor wir
müssen uns fragen
eigentlich den Sonnenaktivitäten ich bin
Politiker ich hoffe dass wir die
Wissenschaft eine Antwort auf diese
Frage auf diese Frage kriege ich ihn
leider keine Antwort die Diskussion ist
wir haben ständig Hysterie und dieser
Alarmismus der schadet eigentlich uns
allen wir sollten uns eigentlich ganz
einfachen Behauptung auf und diskutieren
beantworten gibt es in der natürlich
gibt sie antworten die Frage des
menschlichen Anteils auf das Klima
deswegen hat er Klaus hast wenn man den
Nobelpreis bekommen ist ja längst
beantwortet worden und was sie sagen mit
ihrem anderen Physik Nobelpreisträger
stellen sich mal vor und das will ich
ihn nicht wünschen ja stellen sie mal
vor sie liegen auf ophetisch und dann
komme ich an und will sie operieren und
dann sagen was wollen Sie denn hier sie
noch Klima vor Sie haben keine Ahnung
wieso ich will Wissenschaftler
aufspringen so argumentieren das ist ein
unfairer Vergleich relativ gehen wir
doch mal zu den Instrumenten womit das
angeblich festgestellt wird dass wir
jetzt unbedingt unsere Wirtschaft platt
machen um CO2 einzusparen das sind die
Klima Modelle aber die Klimaforschung
steckt in den Kinderschuhen können noch
nicht mal das Vergangene Klima mit den
Daten die wir haben natürlich lesen und
Behauptungen hier warum sagen
woher kommt das kommt das ich habe mich
mit ihnen beschäftigt ganz kurz meinen
Gedanken den habe ich noch nicht so ganz
okay
ganz kurz noch mal University auf
Alabama ja hat festgestellt wir haben
seit Jahrzehnten eine Erwärmung aber die
ist viel geringer als diese Klimamodelle
vorhergesagt haben schon das widerlegt
das ist eben oder die CO2 sind sie ganz
kurz bitte wir haben genau diese
Diskussion gab es aber die haben sich
Satelliten Daten angeguckt ja und
Satelliten können ja nicht genau an der
Erdoberfläche messen sondern die Messen
immer einen Mittel über die ganze im
Moment Moment messen ein Mittel über ein
gewissen Teil der Atmosphäre ja und das
ist ja klar dass ich das an der
Oberfläche Stärke erwärmt als in seiner
mittleren Atmosphären Schichten ja und
dann wenn man so Mittelwert bildet dann
hat natürlich eine geringe Stimmung und
das hat man die schon längst entkräfte
das ist ein Argument aus der Mottenkiste
war schon seit vielen Jahren tatsächlich
wieder nicht worden ist wir haben
westpunkte die haben sich verschoben
weil sich die Städte ausgedehnt haben
und jetzt auch naturgemäß angehalten
Fehler in diesen Fehler Modellen ist
schon mal größer als weiß ich nicht äh
die 45 Grad im Raum stehen nämlich von 0
bis 6 Kelvin
kann
operieren Simulation von vor 30 Jahren
mit dem was passiert ist und das passt
für die Frau das sagen sie so es passt
passt wie die Faust das Auge noch mal
deswegen wurde er der Physik Nobelpreis
an Hassmann und manabi verliehen weil
genau es passt und sie behaupten jetzt
genau wieder Besserung behaupte ich
jetzt mal das ist nicht schlimm
es ging doch damals als er Nobelpreis
verdient wurde so durch die Presse wenn
sie das nicht mitbekommen haben dann
kann ich ihn nicht mehr genauso
funktioniert
genauso funktioniert auch der
gesellschaftliche Diskurs und ich habe
es ehrlich gesagt geahnt und deswegen
habe ich auch die Anmoderation so
geschrieben die Vorstellungsrunde und
würde jetzt gerne Melanie Ammann Fragen
an dem Punkt wie gehen wir damit um zwar
sehr interessant sagte ich habe eine
andere Meinung und ich sag dann immer ja
gut jeder hat ein Recht auf eigene
Meinung wir sind glücklicherweise ein
freies liberales Land jeder kann denken
und sagen was immer möchte aber niemand
hat ein Recht auf eigene Fakten das
natürlich was anderes ich frage ihn
mehrfach nach Fakten nach namenszahlen
Daten und er schwimmt ein bisschen
schwimmt doch nicht doch doch wir haben
okay okay
wir haben ganz offen wir können uns als
Gesellschaft das war meine Eingang these
immer schwerer auf eine gemeinsame
Wirklichkeit einigen und ich will das
gar nicht werten ich schlage mich in
diesem Streit darauf gar keine Seite ich
will nur sagen das ist schwierig weil
dann kannst du politisch nicht mehr
richtig agieren wenn du etwas beschließt
etwas machst weißt du du hast die Hälfte
deines Landes gegen dich und wenn du es
anders machst hast du die andere Hälfte
gegen dich das heißt irgendwann kommen
wir als Gesellschaft an so einem Punkt
wo es nicht mehr weitergeht so ist es
und ich finde diese Versuchsanordnung
hier
zeigt das dass wir da auf ein ganz ganz
schlimmen weg sind weil wir haben hier
zwei Menschen sitzen der eine ist ein
international anerkannter Fachmann in
seinem Gebiet der die Meinung hat die
auch würde ich sagen 99,5% der Menschen
die sich auskennen mit dem Thema die
sich fachlich auskennen mit dem Thema
vertritt der hier mit den Fakten
argumentiert und wir haben jemanden der
Entschuldigung aber ein Populisten der
mit seiner Meinung dagegen hält und mit
einer Suppe aus
hier und da ein paar Namen die in den
Raum geworfen werden von Menschen deren
Qualifikationen in keiner Weise mit der
von Händler tief ebenbürtig ist
sozusagen operiert und hier eine Zahl
dort die University auf Alabama also
einfach ein Mischmasch aus das zweifeln
sehr sehen soll letztendlich das
Nebelkerzen wirft und wo ich
wahrscheinlich vermute dass die Leute am
Fernseher sich sagen gut da sitzen zwei
die sind offensichtlich
unterschiedlicher Meinung und das
Problem ist dass wir aber eine schiefe
Ebene haben wir haben den einen der
wirklich sich damit auskennt der seit
sein ganzes Leben der Forschung zu
diesem Thema verschrieben hat und wir
haben einen äh der das Thema
populistisch ausschlachtet und die
werden aber letzten Endes aus dieser
Diskussion rausgehen als halt zwei Leute
mit unterschiedlichen Meinungen und das
ist genau
die diskursverschiebung die in den
Jahren seit der Gründung der AFD
gelungen ist die ist auf vielen
politischen Ebenen gibt dies beim Thema
Russland Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
gibt die ist die auch während der
flüchtlingskrise existierte die bei alle
und die eben auch ein investierter
Versuch ist Institutionen zu
delegitimieren Fachkompetenz zu
delegitimieren und der auch ja am
Endeffekt verhindert dass eine gebildete
aufgeklärte Gesellschaft sich ein Bild
machen kann weil also diese diese
Diskussion die zielte darauf ab also so
Oppositionelle Meinungen rauszuhalten
denn ja was man diskutiert die AFD
verschiebt nicht die Diskussion sondern
die veröffentlichte Meinung und auch die
Bundesregierung Willen Diskurs
verhindern auf vielen vielen Ebenen
schauen Sie mal die Meinungsfreiheit
bitte darauf zwei Drittel der Deutschen
wollen sich öffentlich nicht mehr äußern
zu den Themen Migration Islamisierung
gender Homosexualität
die Meinungsfreiheit ist in Gefahren
möchten verstehen
sportbeitrag als expertenbeitrag
wahrgenommen wird oder ob ihr dort
Beitrag und ihre Meinung nein ich
erkläre ihnen nur wie es gemeint habe es
geht darum ob ihr Wortbeitrag vom Inhalt
her und von der Sachaussage her das zum
Thema Klima auf der dasselbe Gewicht und
dieselbe noch nicht erklären ob er
dasselbe Gewicht und dieselbe Bedeutung
hat wie die Aussage von jemanden
der Wissenschaft verschrieben hat das
ist der Punkt der Punkt ist nicht dass
sie nicht sagen dürfen wie die Dinge
sind wie sie die Dinge sehen danke schön
wie Sie persönlich die welche Meinung
sie haben aber es bleibt oder eine
Meinung das ist ja eben diese Meinung
sondern was relativ hat ist
Fachkompetenz ja mehr als alle hier ja
und das sie sagen sie stellen sie sagen
bitte lass uns alle Argumente
austauschen bitte also nochmal mein
Punkt ist und den habe ich glaube ich
gemacht dass wir zwei Menschen zu einem
Thema diskutieren die beide ihre Meinung
sagen können nur der Unterschied ist
dass die Meinung das einen mit
Fachkompetenz unterfüttert ist und die
Meinung des anderen ist mit Populismus
und Politiker müssen sich damit
auseinandersetzen und relativ ist eben
der Wissenschaftler und es gibt aber
auch neben ihm andere und die haben eben
eine andere Meinung konnten
mal
sagen welchen Wissenschaftler das
gesamte das Problem ist
und wenn ich Herrn Latif noch mal fragen
kann von irgendjemandem der Mann genannt
haben
ich weiß nicht ob wir also die die
fremden Planeten jetzt und deren
Konstellation erklären können die Erde
ist ein so komplexes System ich glaube
das haben sie gesagt dass wir dort keine
Aussage treffen können mit einer solchen
Wucht dass wir in Deutschland unsere
Energieversorgung zerstören dass wir aus
zwei Energieform gleichzeitig aussteigen
dass das World Street Journal sagt wir
machen die schlimmste Energiepolitik der
Welt und dass die Leute ja gezwungen
werden jetzt irgendwie die Heizungen zu
zu auszu also zu ändern oder
beziehungsweise dürfen keine anderen
Heizung einbauen werden gezwungen ihr
Häuschen zu sanieren und das ist eine
Politik die führt in die Katastrophe die
Verhältnismäßigkeit fehlt auch und
vielleicht dann ja kommen wir nochmal
zurück sie haben jetzt die
Zusammenarbeit festgestellt mit der CO2
Konzentration und dann diesen 15 Grad
Durchschnittstemperatur oder so
wie wie ist das unterlegt das ist ja
eben so die spannende Frage ich ich habe
da kein niemanden auch erklären kann sie
kommen raus Brandenburg es gab letztes
Jahr in Brandenburg 400 Waldbrände es
wurde ein Millionen Schaden angerichtet
also Brandenburg ist quasi
wahrscheinlich wird auch auf diesen
Sommer wieder eine das baul sein in der
Leute nicht nur ihr Leben verlieren
können ihre Existenz verlieren können in
der Feuerwehrleute die ja der AFD immer
sehr am Herzen liegen wohl zumindest in
den Worten deswegen ist immer heißt dass
es wir sind die Freunde der Polizei in
der Feuerwehrleute also die auch ihr
Leben und ihre Gesundheit aufs Spiel
setzen um diese Waldbrände zu bekämpfen
ich frage mich da oder ich würde gerne
den Politiker kontré fragen
was was tun sie oder was trägt die
Klimapolitik der AFD dazu bei die
Menschen in Brandenburg zu schützen vor
solchen Ereignissen das auch wieder ein
ganz spannender Punkt ob also die
Temperaturerhöhung mit diesen extremen
wettern zusammenhängen und ich glaube
sie haben da auch was anderes gesagt das
kann korrelieren muss aber nicht und ähm
wenn ich also mal das Radio anschalte
dann wird eben immer wieder gesagt das
hat extrem zugenommen aber mir ist jetzt
also keine belastbare Studie bekannt
ist
also wirklich so viel kann zugenommen
nicht das gefühlte gefühlt
sehen wir alle müssen nur das Fernsehen
anderen gefühlt ist alles
jetzt schlimm aber
es gibt keine wissenschaftliche
Grundlage die also darlegen kann dass
wir wirklich mit einer Häufung von
extremwertern
beginnen oder die Daten des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes bei uns in Deutschland
die beginnen 1881 anhand dieser Daten
kann man ganz eindeutig ablesen das
Wetter extreme zunehmen zum Beispiel die
Hitze Tage ja die haben bei uns in
Deutschland massiv zugenommen und Hitze
Tage sind Tage an denen die
Tageshöchsttemperatur 30 Grad erreicht
oder darüber sprechen sind gerade in
Hamburg sozusagen
sind wir gerade in Hamburg ja wir hatten
letztes Jahr das allererste Mal seit
Beginn der Messung Temperaturen über 40
Grad hat es noch nie gegeben ja und sie
stellen sich jetzt her hin und sagen
dass es alles Zufall ja ich kann x
andere Beispiele nennen ich kann den
statistisches signifikante Trends nennen
anhand der Messung die wir haben die
zeigen dass extrem Wetter zugenommen
haben und jetzt setzen Sie sich hier hin
und sagen es stimmt nicht auf welcher
Datenbasis machen Sie diese Aussagen
worauf berufen sie sich ich kenne keine
Frage gerne ich habe jetzt versuchen
keine Datenbank beantworten Grund oder
auf der Basis derer man tatsächlich
sagen kann die Wetter extreme haben
nichts zugenommen ja ich will also die
Diskussion eigentlich immer wieder
versachlichen aber das klappt eben
leider nicht
zu tun haben
argumentieren aber nee das doch nee das
war sie und nein
mein Gefühl ist wenn ich so das Radio
anhören
aber eigentlich ist doch ganz anders
brachte sie hat dieses Gefühl
geantwortet auf die Frage übrigens
Kollegen aus der Regie haben das gerade
recherchiert 2017 zusammen mit anderen
auf die Straße gegangen weil er sich
Luft machen wollte weil er sauer war
über klimaleugner das ist der Mann den
sie gerade das Kronzeugen zitieren Klima
ich weiß nicht wen sie damit meint
ich muss jetzt kurz nachdenken aber ich
habe eine Idee darüber streiten
hier als Argument in die Runde geworfen
ich habe zitiert wollen wir noch mal
zurückspulen dann hören wir uns das mal
an was haben sie zitiert
ich werde hier nicht noch mal
wiederholen weil es einfach
gut also für sie noch mal dann ne ich
glaube die anderen haben es mitbekommen
also der Zeilinger hat gesagt dass ich
die Wissenschaft nicht sicher sein kann
die Zukunft verehrt zu sagen mit
Sicherheit so das ist ja das ist ja ein
ganz allgemein gültiger Satz auch
relativ unterschreiben dürft aber genau
unterschreiben würde und sogar Forschung
zu der passt hier also genau dieser Mann
ist auf die Straße gegangen aus Protest
gegen Klimaneutralität
aber sicher kein Kronzeugen Thesen
sicherlich jemand als Klima Leugner
bezeichnet dann will ich ihn nicht
ausreden lassen will ich ihn
stigmatisieren okay und das ist das
Problem okay okay
in vielen Bereichen wir diskutieren
einfach viel zu wenig also nicht mal
nicht wir kommen vielleicht nachher noch
mal zum Thema wir haben gerade noch mal
den gesamten Satz von Herrn Zeilinger
den sie gerade sehr coole zitiert haben
noch mal rausgesucht ja wissen sie
wieder geht gar nicht also die
Verfälschung und verloren von Tatsachen
zu ideologischen Zwecken
und an dem Punkt kommen sie ins Spiel
bedrohen nicht nur die Wissenschaft
sondern auch die Grundlagen der
Demokratie das ist das krasse Gegenteil
dessen was sie gerade hier in simuliert
und in den Raum geworfen haben warum
zitieren Sie diesen Mann aber
Lanzen
beschäftigen
es ist 20 23 sie können Sie auch morgen
auf ihrer Seite machen das ist egal
genau sie werden aber nichts anderes
finden ja
ich habe ihn den Satz zitiert sie haben
völlig anderen Satz zitiert kann man so
machen ja ist aber jetzt nicht gut dass
dir okay sie berufen sich auch auf ihrer
Seite häufig auf das
europäische Institut für Klima und
Energie
ist ein Begriff für wir sind wichtig für
sie was ist das das ist zumindest eine
Seite von der man mal Impulse bekommen
kann wie natürlich auch von ihnen her
relativ und dann kann man sich die
Meinung bilden ja das sind das ist aus
europäische Institut für Klima und
Energie
dieser Diskussion zu tun doch eine Menge
eine Menge hier doch doch doch doch doch
also wir suchen Daten und Fakten immer
ganz kurz also leute wie Sie und noch
was hat nichts mit ihm persönlich zu tun
Herr Kollege ich habe überhaupt nichts
gegen sie aber ich habe was dagegen dass
man so die Dinge so verdreht und ich
habe was gegen diese nee nee nee das
geht so nicht sie sie rufen sich auch
auf Menschen wie diese von diesem
europäischen Institut für klimat Energie
ich sage immer ganz kurz die Fakten dazu
der Vereinsgründer und Präsident ist
Holger tust wissen Sie wer das ist
das ist nicht unser Thema
irgendjemanden raus und wer ist dieser
Mann wir sollten lieber über Daten
sprechen eben wie kommt dieser zusammen
ich versuche gerade zu sprechen
15 Grad die davon abhängt oder wie die
Klimaforschung also kaum auch die Erde
erklären kann und dann aber sagen will
wie die Planeten sich entwickeln um ihre
Argumentation zu unterfüttern auf ihrer
Webseite Institut für Klima und Energie
Frage
der Gründer dieses dieses
klimaaniert
ist doch richtig
richtig der energiepolitische Sprecher
der AFD sie berufen sich auf ihrer
Website in ihrer Argumentation ganz
häufig auf genau dieses Institut auf die
Fakten die dort vermitteln deswegen noch
mal die Frage der Gründer dieses
Instituts ist Holger thuß wer ist Holger
Tours kennen sie denn das ist völlig
irrelevant
im Raum stehen
weil mir die Nase desjenigen nicht
gefällt der das wirklich um die Nase sie
kennen ihn gar nicht also Holger tut
sich dann ehemaliger
cdu-kommunalpolitiker aus Jena der
Pressesprecher ist horst-joachim
Lübecker kennen Sie den hat nichts mit
den Fakten zu tun können über die Dinge
die im Raum stehen nämlich dass wir
einen klimaalerismus haben
wie argumentieren und das ganz
interessantes dort im Prinzip
ganz kurz der Presse sprechen dieses
Instituts auf das sie sich so häufig
Berufen ist Haus Joachim
pensionierter Professor für
Strömungsmechanik der sagt wir brauchen
keine Klimaforschung weil es gibt gar
kein wissenschaftlichen Beweis dafür
dass CO2 die Erde aufheizt das sind die
Leute auf die sich berufen
aber jetzt mal eine Gegenfrage das ist
eine Position welche Position warum
zitieren Sie dann oder warum haben sie
was
gegen den Herrn warum setzt man sich
dann nicht mit seiner Aussage
auseinander was mache ich doch gerade
wir brauchen keine Klimaforscher sagt
der der Mann vom Institut für Klima und
Energie das heißt er stellt sich selber
eigentlich in Frage
aber ich mache häufig mit
und es geht wieder es geht darum dass
sie ein Großteil ihrer Position damit
legitimieren dass es sagen es gibt da
das Institut Eike und die sagen das auch
und
wie auch das Institut gesagt dass wir
versuchen jetzt und wir haben
versuchen klar zu machen
fachliche Expertise
von diesem roten Faden wegfahren was
bedeutet es was bedeutet es wenn ich
diese
dann sehen wir dass also die Grünen
daraus honigsaugen Politik machen und
wir morgen die Industrialisierung haben
zum Teil haben wir sie jetzt schon aber
morgen die Initialisierung haben
damit ist keinem geholfen es sie hat der
Aussage stimme ich völlig zu also die
Frage nach dem politischen Konsequenzen
ist eine völlig andere und die würde ich
ehrlich gesagt Ihnen auch immer gerne
stellen wenn sie sagen ich bin
energiepolitischer Sprecher der AFD sie
sind in Ostdeutschland ja kurz davor
echt relevante Zahlen einzufahren sie
sind bundesweit irgendwo zwischen Frau
Mann helfen sie mir zwischen 15 bis 17
%. so dass das ist ziemlich relevant das
heißt es könnte der Tag auf Sie zukommen
dann nehmen sie nicht mehr einfach drei
populistische Positionen werfen
die was ganz anderes gesagt haben
sondern es könnte der Tag auf sie zu von
dem sie ernsthaft seriös politisch
arbeiten müssen und treffen müssen also
keine Angst machen wir jetzt schon
überhaupt kein Problem okay der Eindruck
drängt sich mir heute Abend noch nicht
auf aber ich lasse mich gerne alles
besseren belehren wie machen wir es dann
was passiert dann sie sagen es gibt
keinen menschengemachten Klimawandel
aber es gibt ein Klimawandel was heißt
das für sie als AFD sie werden es morgen
in der Regierung sie würden was würden
Sie machen würden sie alles so
weiterlaufen ganz kurz korrigieren ich
sage nicht dass es keine
menschengemachte Komponente an der
Klimaveränderung gibt ach doch aber ich
habe doch vorhin in die Runde gestellt
es gibt schon bei der Frage wie wirkt
das CO2 und hat es wirklich diese
Wirkung wie immer behauptet sich die
Leute streiten und dort man nicht
streichelt sich darüber nicht wieder hat
und das Problem ich Verhältnismäßigkeit
stimmt nicht Sicherheit kommen
annehmen dass wir ab heute Moment wenn
wir annehmen dass wir ab heute keine
Treibhausgase mehr aufstoßen dann
bleiben wir tatsächlich unter den 1,5
Grad die auch im Pariser Klimaabkommen
stehen wenn wir aber immer weiter kommen
wenn wir immer weiter steigern ja dann
werden wir das Pariser Klimaabkommen
reißen krachen verfehlen und dann werden
wir irgendwann vielleicht bei diesen 4
Grad
sind wir irgendwann bei diesen vier
gerade bis zum Ende des Jahrhunderts
eine unglaubliche Temperaturänderung nur
niemand kann vorher sagen wie wir uns
verhalten ich auch nicht das sind also
sozusagen wenn dann Rechnungen die wir
durchführen und ich kann ihn nur sagen
das was wir in den 70ern in den 80er
Jahren gerechnet haben ist tatsächlich
genauso eingetreten natürlich muss man
damals auch nicht wie sich das CO2
entwickeln würde aber wir haben
angenommen in verschiedenen rechnen Sie
sich so oder so entwickeln und wenn wir
das nehmen wie sich tatsächlich der CO2
Gehalt entwickelt hat dann stimmen die
Berechnung für das Klima eben genau mit
dem überein wie es heute eingetreten ist
das heißt also man darf nicht die
Unsicherheit der Modelle verwechseln mit
der sogenannten szenarienunsicherheit
kein Mensch weiß ja wie wir uns in den
zu in der Zukunft verhalten werden und
deswegen gibt es natürlich eine riesen
Bandbreite aber diese Bandbreite hat
doch nichts mit den Klimamodellen zu tun
sondern mit der Frage wie wir uns in der
Zukunft verhalten sind aber mal eine
Frage
dreist wenn wir keine Wirtschaft mehr
haben keine CO2 mehr ausstoßen was ist
dem Weltklima geholfen das ist eine
politische Frage die sie jetzt
ansprechen die jetzt erstmal mit der
wissenschaftlich zu tun deswegen
komm alles gut wir haben das verstanden
angenommen sie werden jetzt sie werden
es der neue Bundeswirtschaftsminister
welche Energiequellen haben Sie welche
Klima und Energiepolitik machen sie so
also wir haben Gas wir haben Öl kommt
das wir haben Kernenergie Gas kommt
wieder aus Russland wenn man sich wieder
anmachen okay und wir haben vor allen
Dingen Kernenergie Kernenergie erlebt
eine Renaissance ist leider hier in
Deutschland ja durch
verschiedenste grünen idiotinen
abgestellt worden leider überall in
Europa in der Welt macht man wieder
Kernenergie ist auch CO2 Arm also das
wäre im Prinzip eine Sache die also
denjenigen auch
CO2 na ja weil wir mit Kernenergie die
preiswerteste Energieform haben und das
stimmt eben nicht dass die sogenannten
instabilen Erneuerbaren preiswert sind
müssen immer noch subventioniert werden
und Windstrom fängt bei 18 an gerne
Energie ist in der Herstellung bei drei
bis fünf sein und sie würden neue
Kernkraftwerke bauen selbstverständlich
nur Deutschland beschreitet den würden
wir sofort beenden endlich wieder
preiswerte Energie zu bekommen denn das
ist ja eine Idiotie die hier läuft wir
haben keine preiswerte Energie sie wird
verteuert und damit helfen wir auch
nicht weltweit
verstanden
der nächsten Generation zerstören dann
haben wir natürlich Probleme
eigentlich nicht machen wir hätten die
Kernkraftwerke noch da das heißt er
könnte noch mal ganz kurz also sie
würden in ihrem Wahlkreis würden sie den
AKW hinstellen nur selbstverständlich
würden sie machen ja natürlich okay
weil es kein Problem
Reststoffe die dann verwertet werden
können und diese diese
in der Rede stehen die kann man dann
durchaus wieso wie es jetzt ist Musik
kein Mensch weiß doch wirklich was wir
mit dem Atommüll anfangen sollen ja uns
ist seit Jahrzehnten seit Beginn der
zivilen Nutzung Atomkraft ist uns
erzählt worden
zu finden wir haben das heute gefunden
Dinge in den Raum zu stellen die in
keiner Weise irgendeine
wissenschaftliche Basis aber gerade
vorstellen
keine Lösung es gibt keine Lösung nicht
durcheinander bitte sie sagten gerade
Kernen Energizer so wahnsinnig stimmt
natürlich nicht doch nein keine Energie
sehr sehr teuer
der ganze der ganze der ganze Bereich
der Atome Energie in Frankreich ist hoch
defizitär deswegen ist das sind die
ganzen akadem doch auch so marode